So we could that with two imports. We could also do it with just one line
listing the two with commas, and we would add this line to test.py. Usually
we'll put the imports at the beginning of the file. If we did this where we
actually use things from the imported modules, but we would need to use
crawler.crawl_web instead of just crawl_web here. And instead of ordered search
for example, we would need to use search.orderedsearch. If there's a definition
in a module that we need to use frequently, we might not want to have to type
the module name before every time we use it. So there's a way to import names
from a module directly into our name space, and that's to use from. The syntax
is from, followed by the module name, import, and then the list of definitions
that we want to import from that module into our name space. So for this
example, we do from crawler import crawl_web, compute_ranks.